Franklin Richards is one of the most
overpowered characters in the history of
Marvel Comics check this out so this guy
named Jonathan Hickman basically starts
writing Fantastic Four and you end up
learning that these celestials from an
alternate reality invade the main Marvel
universe so they can conquer it and then
move on to the next one and do the same
so the first person to try to stop them
is Galactus the three celestials merge
and they kill Galactus on the spot now
following that Susan's storm with a
Fantastic Four has a force field doing
what you can to try to keep her family
alive and then Franklin Richards from
the future comes to the Past he borrows
the powers of his younger self he
resurrects Galactus from the dead and
one of the greatest moments where he's
like to me my Galactus and with the two
of them using their power together what
follows is one of the most spectacular
whoopings in the history of Marvel
Comics it was absolutely amazing they
demolished the celestials make sure you
guys follow for more